from 1985 to 1955 to 1885 here's doc
brown's entire back to the future
timeline explained
doc and marty's time traveling
adventures in back to the future all
started with a clock
on november 5th 1955 doc brown decided
to hang a clock over the toilet in his
bathroom
while balancing on his toilet doc fell
and hit his head knocking himself
unconscious
when he came too he'd had a vision a
picture in my head
a picture of this this is what makes
time travel possible
the flux capacitor over the following 30
years dock was successful in creating a
working flux capacitor which he
installed in a delorean
meanwhile on november 12 the week after
dock fell off his toilet the clock tower
at the hill valley
courthouse was struck by lightning three
decades after inventing the flux
capacitor doc finishes his time machine
but there's just one small
problem in order to run his machine
requires 1.21 gigawatts of power which
is significantly more than a car battery
can produce
dock solution plutonium dock you don't
just walk into a store
and buy plutonium marty's right but doc
figures out a way to acquire the
radioactive substance by making a deal
with a group of libyan terrorists to
build them a bomb
he steals their plutonium and gives them
a bomb casing filled with used pinball
machine parts
obviously this doesn't end well on
october 26
1985 doc asked marty to come help him
document the first test of his time
machine but no sooner as he conducted a
successful test with his dog einstein
then the terrorists show up
marty hides but the terrorists open fire
and kill doc as a traumatized marty
looks on
marty then tries to escape in the
delorean still programmed by doc for the
day he first invented time travel
bringing him back to november 5th
1955. soon after receiving his vision of
the flux capacitor doc brown has just
decided to test out his latest
mind-reading invention when there's a
knock on his door
when he opens it a kid named marty is
standing there claiming to be from the
future
i came here in a time machine that you
invented
now i need your help to get back to the
year 1985.
at first doc doesn't believe him but not
only does marty know how doc
out the bump on his head but he's
carrying a videotape that shows a much
older version of doc himself testing out
a time machine
convinced doc decides to help marty get
back to the future
doc is initially stumped by the power
requirements of the time machine
saying the only thing capable of
producing the necessary 1.21 gigawatts
is a bolt of lightning
however marty happens to know exactly
when and where lightning will strike
the hill valley courthouse clock tower
on the evening of november 12
1955. next saturday night
we're sending you back to the future
over the course of the next week doc
spends his time making models of the
town and fine-tuning his plan to harness
a bolt of lightning into the flex
capacitor
please excuse the crudity of this model
i didn't have time to build it to scale
or to paint it
well doc is trying to make sure all the
pieces are in place to get marty back to
the future
he realizes that marty has accidentally
bungled the timeline preventing his
parents from ever falling in love
horrified at the temporal implications
of what marty has done
doc assists barney and making sure his
parents get together before marty is
erased from existence
after successfully matchmaking marty's
parents doc and marty prepare to channel
the
imminent lightning strike into the
delorean but before marty climbs into
the car he tries to give doc a letter
predicting his future
furious about the possible repercussions
of knowing his own future doc
refuses to read the letter and rips it
up marty is upset but he doesn't have
time to argue
lightning strikes stock's plan is
successful and marty disappears in the
delorean
eventually doc decides to tape the torn
scraps of paper back together and reads
what marty wrote when he does he learns
the truth about his fate
the night that i go back in time you
will be
shot by terrorists
armed with this knowledge doc decides to
make some changes
this time when doc goes to test his time
machine he wears a bulletproof vest
underneath his coveralls and survives
the shooting
when marty asks him what made him change
his mind about the letter doc gives him
an extremely scientific explanation
well i figured what the hell
having survived his formerly fatal
encounter with the terrorists doc
decides his next trip in the time
machine should be to the future
accompanied by his dog einstein doc sets
out for the year 2015.
when doc arrives in 2015 he takes full
advantage of the advanced technology of
the future
he places einstein in a suspended
animation kennel while he modifies the
delorean with a hover conversion
and adds a mr fusion home energy reactor
to circumvent the need for plutonium
doc also goes shopping for new clothes
picks up a sleep inducing alpha rhythm
generator and visits a rejuvenation
clinic to receive an all-natural
overhaul which promises to add 30 to 40
years to his life
however while doc is enjoying all the
amenities the future has to offer he
learns some troubling information about
marty's kids
it turns out that marty's son marty jr
falls in with biff's grandson griff and
his gang and he's with them when they
rob the hill valley payroll substation
marty jr is arrested and sentenced to 15
years in prison even worse marty's
sister marlene tries to break him out of
prison and is subsequently sentenced to
20 years
unable to abide this future for marty's
family doc returns to 1985 to get marty
and change the future
marty you've got to come back with me
where back to the future having picked
up marty and his girlfriend jennifer
from 1985
doc pilots the delorean back to the
future once they arrive doc
immediately knocks jennifer out with his
sleep-inducing alpha rhythm generator
saying she was asking too many questions
after stowing her in an alley doc sends
marty into the cafe 80s with
instructions to keep his son from
getting arrested while marty goes to
meet up with griff doc intercepts marty
jr and uses the same sleep inducing
device on him to keep him from
interfering in doc's plan
doc then picks up einstein from the
suspended animation kennel
after meeting back up with marty doc
learns that he's purchased the sports
almanac that covers the years 1950-2000
doc berates marty for even thinking
about meddling with the timeline and
forces him to throw the almanac away doc
and marty then pick up jennifer and
return to 1985.
when doc and marty get back to 1985 the
timeline is already split thanks to old
biff's tinkering in the past
unfortunately the emmett brown native to
this new timeline has been declared
legally insane and committed to the
mental ward of hill valley hospital
the doc brown has just arrived back from
2015 realizes that something must have
happened to alter the timeline and he
heads to the library to do research
through study and old newspapers he
learns of the unfortunate fate of his
present day counterpart and deduces
what's caused the divergence in the
timeline the sports almanac marty
purchased in 2015.
as it turns out when marty tossed it
aside in 2015 old biff grabbed it stole
the delorean traveled to 1955
and gave it to his younger self ensuring
a future where he could become
tremendously wealthy
doc explains the concept of diverging
timelines to marty who decides to head
off to biff's massive casino hotel to
ask when he acquired the almanac
november 12th 1955 that was when
while marty is talking to biff doc
pilots the delorean to hover just below
the roofline of the towering building
biff follows marty up to the roof where
he intends to kill him but marty jumps
on top of the delorean and doc
uses the car's goal wing doors to knock
biff unconscious
armed with the pivotal dates marty and
doc head back 30 years to restore the
timeline
returning to 1955 once more doc and
marty worked together to steal the
sports almanac from biff in order to
restore the timeline
while there they have to work to avoid
previous versions of themselves who are
still living through the events of the
first film
there are now two of me here and there
are two of you here
after a few failed attempts marty is
successful in retrieving the sports
almanac from biff grabbing it from the
bully's moving car while riding on a
hoverboard
marty narrowly avoids becoming roadkill
when doc drops a rope down to him from
the flying delorean and pulls him to
safety
doc tells marty to burn the almanac
which he does and they confirm
that the timeline is restored however
before doc can land the delorean and
pick up marty to return to 1985 the car
is struck by lightning causing the time
circuits to go haywire and transport him
to 1885.
after he disappears the 1955 version of
doc helps marty figure out how to repair
the delorean that has been stashed since
1885 so that marty can go after him
after realizing that the delorean has
been so damaged by the lightning strike
that there's no hope of repairing it doc
resigns himself to remaining in 1885.
first he hides the delorean in an
abandoned mine shaft and he leaves a
letter with a postal service for marty
telling him how to fix the time machine
so he can return to the future
doc gives the postal service specific
instructions to hold the letter for 70
years
then to deliver it to the person they'll
find at a precise location at a precise
date and time
satisfied that marty will be okay doc
begins building a life for himself
he becomes a blacksmith and after
establishing himself in town doc is
asked to pick up the new school teacher
clara clayton from the train station
he saves her when she loses control of
her horses and the two quickly fall in
love
tragically and not long after meeting
clara doc shoes a horse for buford mad
dog tanet which later throws tannin off
causing him to break a 5
bottle of whiskey tannin shoots the
horse and demands doc pay for both
doc refuses and in retaliation mad dog
shoots him in the back
killing him once marty's arrival splits
the timeline into an alternate 1885
doc rescues marty from mad dog and his
gang initially doc has irritated that
marty came back for him rather than
returning to 1985
but after learning about his death in
the previous timeline he agrees to
return with marty returning to 1985
proves easier said than done since marty
nicked a fuel line in the time machine
when he arrived in 1885.
without a way to self-propel the car
dock catches a plan to hijack a train to
push the delorean up to the necessary 88
miles per hour
however after clara and doc meet and
fall in love she attempts to follow doc
onto the speeding train and winds up
nearly taking a catastrophic tumble onto
the tracks
instead of joining marty and the
delorean doc saves clara missing his
window to return to the future
marty goes back to the future alone and
doc remains in 1885 with clara
fortunately before stealing the train
doc and marty foiled mad dog's plans to
kill doc enabling doc and clara to live
their lives free of tragedy
sometime after marty departs for the
future doc and clara get married and
have two sons jules and vern
during this time doc acquires a new
locomotive engine converts it to steam
power and modifies it to become a time
machine
doc clara and their children ride their
new time machine all the way through the
timeline including a trip to the future
where they upgrade the train engine with
hover technology
when jules and vern are a few years old
doc and clara make a stop in 1985 to
pick up einstein and to introduce marty
to their children
doc gives marty a framed photograph that
they took together back in 1885 and
leaves marty with some last words of
wisdom before taking off her places and
times unknown
your future is whatever you make it so
make it a good one
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one